[Music]
our let's turn now to Chris Pratt in on
affairs did Hollywood's pressures really
contribute to their breakup here's
everything we've learned since their
split life is too short for you to be in
relationships where somebody doesn't
have your back or somebody doesn't value
you in every way
honest POV seems to be I'm practically a
single mom while Chris is away being
famous and shooting movies I'm finding
my voice and my strength again know your
worth know your independence Chris well
he's turning to faith to help him
through the split what did you wife like
more Oh Chris I ripped up Chris she's a
feeder she's a feeder so the wife likes
me better fat thing was a factor his
star power grew after he dropped 70
pounds for guardians but did anyone
cheat we're told no way as for all the
Twitter madness blaming Chris's
passengers co-star j-law for the
break-up I fully support Jennifer
Lawrence wait what that was December
2016 and Chris had just given Anna what
she called an engagement ring upgrade
jury was a gift Pratt often gave his
wife my sweet husband got me this ring
mom on the inside job Chris I know good
not a good gift giver much better than I
have Chris and Anna's son Jack turned
five yesterday no word on how the family
celebrated but there's no doubt Chris
and Anna will make co-parenting work
they stressed our son has two parents
who love him very much
[Music]
you